[Music]
hello everyone my name is Wasim I'm one
of the co-founder and CTO
ater today I'm going to just tell you a
quick story about actually what we
building a trer what we doing but before
we dive in I would love just to give you
quick history of writer so writers we
start the company in 2020 we love to say
the story of writer is the story of the
Transformer we started building those
decoder encoder model in the early days
and we start we kept building those
model and build a lot of them today we
have a family of
models I believe around 16 we published
we have another 20 coming in the way and
we keep building those models and you're
going to see from this list those model
com in two categories General model like
p x p 3 4 if you have a b 5 coming soon
and we have a lot of what's called
domain specific model Creative Financial
Services pal
medical
now early 2024 basically last year
almost we start seeing this trend with
all the LM
basically get very high accuracy in
general the any punish Mark we're see
the accuracy moving and just the growing
and I believe everyone noticing this
accuracy today average accuracy for a
good General models between 80 maybe
close to
so that basically make a bring a
question inside the company saying is it
worth it for us to start building and
keep building domain specifically models
if the accuracy today with General model
achieving around
90% And we have domain specific model
should we just keep building General
models find tunit maybe go Direction
with what you call reasoning or thinking
models and that will be more than enough
actually and we don't need those
financial or what call doain specific
model now to answer this questions we
need
data so whatever we're going to present
next she could be applicable to
financial services domain specific model
sorry to Medical specific model customer
support domain specific model and all
different doain specific model today I'm
going to talk specifically about the
financial spe uh what's called the
financial punchmark for domain specific
model uh we have something similar for
medical but we believe we are but we
start seeing similar result now let me
dive
in just to remind you we're trying to
answer this questions General model the
speciic model should we keep build them
where we actually going from here we
start actually saying great we don't
know the answer let's actually do the
evaluation let's create the data and we
created something called
fail the idea behind it let's create
real word scenario to evaluate those
model and let's see actually of those
new model can really give you the
accuracy that we promise or the accuracy
that we see today from the punch marking
on domain
specific we created two type of
categories in this evaluation something
called query failure in query failure
basically we introduce three type of
subcategories something called Miss
spelling queries you know when you go
ask the llm questions but you do some
spelling error segment error you do some
com comment type of issues weu that to
the eval set we introduce something in
like what called incomplete
queries you're missing some keyword some
stuff not clear we introduce what's
called out of domain queries if you're
not expert in the field or you decide to
copy paste some general answer try to
answer about something very specific and
also intru the second category is what
we call the context failure and the
context failure basically and this get
very interesting we we introduce three
subcategories what called basically
messing context we basically ask the LM
question about context not exist in the
the quest itself in the BR we introduce
what called OCR error today when we do
any kind of OCR or convert physical do
document to text we introduce a lot of
Errors like you know character issues
distance between them the word between
when you do the OCR could be merged
together so we introduce that type of
errors and also we did what call
unrelevant
context let's say you want to ask
question about specific document and you
end up basically uploading completely
wrong document does lm going to still
answer is LM just actually figure out
you have a completely irrelevant
context now when you put all this data
together in domain in financial specific
Financial Service specific you need some
kind of diversity just a quick
screenshot just tell you what amount of
data how much token something worth
mentioning the white paper the data the
evaluation set the leaderboard all
actually open source today available in
GitHub and huging face so anyone please
check it out and we introduce very
simple what you call it evaluation key
Matrix basically we need to look to two
things and the model give the correct
answer can the model actually give good
follow to the grounding or context
grounding or basically what you call it
here the context this is quick or high
level way of how we do the
calculation so to
evaluate we selected a group of models
today we can see a lot of chat model and
also thinking models this is basically
the two list we have here I'm sure you
get familiar with this list and then we
onun the evaluation and we start seeing
very interesting results I'm going to
dive in directly to the result and
basically we start getting something
Fancy with all this color let me switch
to the more what basically
see what's start getting very
interesting we're saying really good
behavior and all thinking models
actually they don't refuse to answer
this sound good most of the time but in
reality when you give something those
llms wrong context when you give them
wrong data when you have a complete
different grounding those model actually
fail fail to follow this part and they
still give you an answer and that
basically get you way higher
hallucination if you start focusing on
the answer itself can the model give me
answer or not you can Fe basically
almost every model from the domain
specific spef the general model they
give you some kind of answer all them
close to each other actually reasoning
or thinking model they get to even
higher score a little bit from there but
when get to the grounding and cona
grounding this is when stuff get more
interesting you can see specifically in
task like text generation or question
answering it's just not performing well
now all does the chart look great what I
prefer is the numb
this is the same data we use to generate
the chart we can go through this really
quick and if you look at this number
here especially for example like the o1
or O3 or B fan you can start noticing
the stuff those model doing amazingly
and basically when you ask with it
misspelled when you got stuff uncomplete
out of domain the numbers look amazing
the model can take a query with mess
spelling wrong grammars or even out of
domain and still can give you the answer
but when you start going to grounding
this is going to startu get very
interesting I'm going to hold this slide
for a second here if did you notice
something
different yep and also those bigger more
thinking give you the worst result
you're getting almost
70 50% to
60% uh worse in the grounding meaning
the model is just not following you
attach in context you ask the questions
and the answers exist outside the
context completely same thing coming to
stuff around it anal context so you can
look at the data and see smaller model
actually performing better than all this
model overthinking at that side and this
is basically it get us about is this
thinking or just a Chain of Thought you
know this could be a lot of argument at
least from the data we have in domain
specific task those model not thinking
at that stage meaning Hallucination is
really high causing a lot of a lot of
issues especially in this fin in this uh
Benchmark we run here in fin Financial
use cases also we can see there's a huge
gap between what call robustness and the
holin
and getting the answer correct so
definitely we still have a lot work to
do to build those model and better
performance but also that get me to you
know to the main idea if you go back
real quick here even with the best model
between all this line we're still not
getting between robustness and cont
grounding more than
81% sounds a great number if you think
in the reality you saying every request
20 of them it's just completely wrong so
that basically what we start seeing
believe at least today with the
technology we have with the current
model we have until we have something
completely different we're seeing you
need full stack you need the rock system
you need
the grounding you need everything from
guard rails and the build around the
system itself to actually have something
relable utilize today in the same
time I would love to go back and answer
the first questions and our first
question
here do you still need to build the
models at least today from the data we
have from run those punch Mark the
answer simply yes we still need to build
and continue domain specific model at
least with the today implementation even
accuracy is keep growing but the
grounding the context for following all
the context correctly it's still way way
way behind from everything we see today
in the
market thank you so much guys
[Music]
[Applause]